Deadpool 2 is finally here, and it left fans
with more than just a stitch in their sides
- it also left them with a lot of questions.
Sure, continuity and logic aren't exactly
important in a Deadpool movie, but there are
still some questions we'd love to have answered
even if those answers have absolutely no meaning.
So grab your stack of X-Force comic books,
button up your 501's, and get ready for a
bumpy ride, because there's a high wind advisory
in effect for the rest of this spoiler-filled
look at the biggest unanswered questions in
Deadpool 2.
Where ARE the other X-Men?
"It's a big house.
It's funny that I only ever see two of you.
It's almost like the studio couldn't afford
another X-Man."
Ryan Reynolds and the rest of the Deadpool
gang have made a lot of hay over the fact
that the only X-Men who appear in the two
Deadpool movies are Colossus and Negasonic
Teenage Warhead.
While it was just a wink and nod one-liner
in the first film, this time around, the rest
of the team actually makes a hilarious cameo,
deliberately avoiding Deadpool because...
well, wouldn't you?
As funny as that was, though, we have to ask:
where exactly are the rest of the X-Men during
the climactic final fight against Juggernaut?
One of the most dangerous mutant menaces in
the world is attacking an orphanage filled
with vulnerable mutant children.
This is the entire reason the X-Men exist
in the first place.
And yet, the only ones who bother to show
up are, you guessed it, Colossus and Negasonic
Teenage Warhead, along with her new girlfriend,
Yukio.
What else could possibly be going on that's
so important Wolverine, Storm, Beast, and
the rest of the team couldn't be bothered
to make an appearance?
Of course, they aren't quite the same without
Hugh Jackman…
"I'm Wolverineeeeeeeeeee.
Claw Drop."
What happened to the rest of X-Force?
Arguably the funniest part in Deadpool 2 is
the amazing sequence where the newly formed
X-Force tries to parachute down to attack
the convoy carrying Russell, only for almost
every single one of them to be horribly - and
hilariously - killed off in graphic and preposterous
ways.
Saddest of all, of course, is the death of
gregarious everyman Peter thanks to acid vomit
taking out one of his arms - which kinda sucks.
Luckily, during the end credits scene, Deadpool
uses Cable's time machine to go back in time
and change events so Peter is saved.
Which begs the question: what happened to
the rest of X-Force?
Did Deadpool bother to save the lives of the
rest of the team he assembled?
Or did he only save Peter?
We never find out, though his comment about
how nobody liked Shatterstar suggests at least
one member of the team might not be back for
Deadpool 3.
"X-Force!"
What's the deal with Cable?
In the comics, Cable has a lot going on.
He's actually from our time period, sent to
the future to save him from the techno-virus
that is slowly turning him into a robot.
He's also the son of Cyclops and Jean Grey's
evil clone, and usually uses his inherited
telepathic and telekinetic abilities to keep
the virus in check.
Oh, and he comes back from the future to protect
the prophesied mutant messiah, Hope, who he
adopts as his daughter.
"I'm Cable.
And I'm from the future.
And I like blowing s--- up."
So, like... is any of that at all happening
in the movies?
Is he still Scott and Jean's son?
Is Hope an adopted mutant messiah?
Does he have the technovirus, or is that just
a robot arm?
Does he have mutant powers?
At several points in Deadpool 2 his weapons
fly across the room to him - is that telekinesis,
or some kind of technological gadget?
In short, we know almost nothing about the
movie version of Cable.
Here's hoping we get to know a lot more about
him in the future - no pun intended.
Is Vanessa actually Death?
So… is Vanessa actually the avatar of Death?
Bear with us on this one.
In the first Deadpool film, Wade Wilson has
a super healing factor that even kept him
from dying when he was stabbed through the
brain.
That's pretty powerful.
But in Deadpool 2, his power levels seem to
be cranked up more than a few notches.
In fact, he completely blows himself apart
in the opening sequence, with his head flying
off and all his limbs going every direction,
only to get pieced back together.
In effect, Deadpool is now immortal, something
he mentions several times in the film, claiming
he just can't die.
This is actually true in the comics, where
Wade falls in love with Death, who takes the
form of a beautiful woman.
Death has a jealous ex, though, who you might
know: Thanos.
He curses Deadpool with immortality so that
Wade and Death can never be together, only
meeting occasionally in brief flashes of the
afterlife when he is literally on death's
door - just to be yanked back to life no matter
how hard he tries.
That sounds a whole lot like the relationship
Wade and Vanessa have throughout Deadpool
2 after she is killed in the opening sequence.
Sure, he eventually brings her back to life
during the end credits sequence.
But still, we have to wonder if Vanessa is
actually Death, which would explain why he
can't die, why he sees her when he's close
to dying, and even why he got cancer as soon
as they started a relationship.
Hmm!
Will there be a Deadpool 3?
Finally, the big question on everyone's mind:
will there even be a Deadpool 3?
With Deadpool 2 set to become another box
office smash, it's a no brainer that the folks
at 20th Century Fox would love to make another
one.
And fans are certainly clamoring for it.
But Ryan Reynolds recently told Entertainment
Weekly that he's not so sure.
Why?
Well, for the best of reasons: he's not convinced
it would be a good story, saying.
"In order for [Deadpool] to function properly
within his own universe, you need to take
everything away from him.
I don't think that you can keep doing that.
I do see him as being a part of X-Force, obviously.
I would love to see him in a team-up sort
of thing.
[...] I just think if you're going to do another
Deadpool solo film, you've got to really,
like, get that budget down to nothing and
just swing for the fences, and break all kinds
of weird barriers, and do stuff that no one
else can do."
Luckily, there's an X-Force film currently
in development, and the end of the film certainly
seems to set up a team spinoff.
So one way or another, there looks to be more
Deadpool in our future - and hopefully, more
Peter too.
That guy is the best.
"As it turns out, we're looking for someone
with Diabetes."
"Peter's your man."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!